hello and welcome to this evening's
meeting of planning and development
management committee
uh just by way of introduction my name
is aiden williams and i serve as the
german committee
also present on this call of the
committee
vice chair councillor ben hartley
offices from the council's planning
service
legal and democratic services local
highway authority as well as the elected
councillors who make up voting members
of the planning committee before we
continue i should
advise everyone's information that this
meeting has been live streamed and
recorded
so please mute your microphones to
minimize background noise
if you wish to speak on an item please
use the chat facility to notify me
and then wait until you're invited to
speak
um turn into the agenda um
gender item one is attendances i think
all members are present by
councillor bunting who i understand may
be joining us later
um item two declarations of interest are
there any
members wishing to declare an interest
20 items
no okay um item three
is minutes um to receive and if so
determine
to approve as correct a record of the
minutes the meetings held
11th and 15th of march members happy to
move in second now
to move chair
okay in our second map which will take
those as approved
uh item four is questions from members
of the public
um not being
received uh agenda item five it's the
additional information report that's
been circulated to members via email
earlier today and then agenda item six
is applications for permission to
develop
um the first application that we'll
consider this evening is
432 flixster mode which is on page one
of the committee reports
and before we hear from any
representations for members of the
public
the item is going to be introduced by ms
coley
thank you chairman just bear with me
while i share my screen
everybody see that yeah excellent
okay um this application relates to 432
flicks
road in flexton um which is a former
cafe within a row of commercial
retail units at ground floor several of
those
these units including application sites
and those on either side
having separate apartments above
the former cafe used included an
external seating area and the hours of
use were limited to
uh to close at six pm on mondays to
saturdays and three p
on sundays so that's there's the unit
there you can see it within
within the row and you've got
residential properties there
retrospective planning application
planning permission is sought for the
change of the
use of this unit to a bar with an
outdoor seating and drinking area
a new glazed main elevation with by four
fold doors in the front door
and an external cooling unit the latter
of which to the rear elevation
in addition extended hours of user sort
10 pm on mondays to thursdays
and 11 pm on fridays and saturdays you
see the
event the front elevation there is
proposed and the floor plan
there and then the
um as built rear elevation
there with the air conditioning unit and
the extractor hood
the retrospective application was
submitted following complaints from
neighbouring properties
and a number of objections have been
received which is summarized in the
officer report following advice from the
council's nuisance consulting the
applicant has carried out sound proofing
works to the unit
and produced a noise management plan in
an effort to limit the bar's immunity
impacts to an acceptable level
and you see a photograph there of the
unit
as it looks at the moment this is
retrospective
um with with the apartment above and
then there's a
um unfortunately we have to take this
google street view so do forgive the uh
markers across the front but you can see
the the wider context there of the
of the row which which it's in so the
key
issue for consideration is the bar's
immunity impact on surrounding occupants
officers recognize the applicant has
made efforts to satisfy the nuisance
consulting
in carrying out sound proofing measures
and drawing up the noise management plan
and the nuisance consultancy has
subsequently confirmed no objection to
the
application subject to conditions
notwithstanding this
it is considered that having regard to
the lack of civil and late night
bar and pub uses in the vicinity of the
application site
significant number of objections from
neighbours in close proximity to the
site
the large forecast in front of the
premises where there is the potential
for people to gather
the use results in an unacceptable noise
and immunity impact on the occupants
of nearby residential properties in this
context
officers do not consider that the
proposed noise management plan
and or the imposition of additional
planning conditions to control noise and
disturbance
will acceptably address these concerns a
number of the suggested
measures would not be enforceable
through planning powers the application
is therefore recommended for refusal
thank you chairman
thank you mrs coley um there is a
speaker
against this um application alex brady
cross your understand has submitted a
statement that will be read up by mr
dave
yes thank you chair um yeah i'm going to
read the statements of
alex priority kosh um and i do want to
just emphasize
that these are the voiced opinions are
those of the
objects and not those of officers
okay as landlord of four of the
neighboring units to brew chimp
i have great concern on how the bar has
and will continue to affect my tenants
a tenant left in december 2019 when he
found out a bar would be opening
below and i struggled to find new
tenants as they all had the same
concerns
brew chimp has caused disruption and
concern for everyone
and i have great concern that the
proprietor of bruce him
appears to lack honesty and the ability
to follow
any rules and therefore if he is granted
any official permissions
to do what he's already been doing
without the correct permission
it would appear that any official rules
implied
will be further ignored
such example as obtaining a sound report
and then having bifold doors fitted
in july 2020 by only requesting planning
permission
in due in january 2021
which will negatively impact on the
results of the sound report
allowing tables outside on the pavement
past the permitted time
which was given to the previous cafe
owner of 6 pm i believe
photo evidence previously supplied
which caused noise and disturbance to
the residential tenants in the flats
above
yes my tenants did complain
and i have expressed concern about how
long they would reside there for
should he be granted the licences and
permissions brutium are seeking
the brew chimp owner certainly hasn't
given an impression
of someone who is honest and completely
prepared to follow the rules
the complete opposite in fact
my concerns are echoed by my tenants in
all four of our units
the bar is detrimental to surrounding
businesses
nobody wants people stood outside their
premises their business premises
smoking and drinking nor do they want
their customers to have to endure it
either
and it is detrimental to the residential
tenants
most of which have lived there happily
for a number of years
i know one of my tenants who is a young
single parent
is particularly worried and greatly
concerned
how she will go about finding and
affording another home locally
in the summer when everyone has their
windows and doors open
smell and noise pollution will only be
more intense
thank you
thank you mr day um there is a speaker
speaking in favor of the application of
david lee
is mr leap um
[Music]
designated as user on on the screen
mr lee can you can you hear us
if we're unable to get a hold of mr lee
there is a statement
in statement yeah we do we do have a
written statement yes
um
just having a bit of um trouble i think
with your audio mr lee
i think councilor bunting's joined a
call as well now
the looks of it
hello hi yes sorry i apologize to all i
t problems my computer decided it had to
do some updates
when i tried to join the meeting and
through everyone let me join sorry about
that so i'll take it we've started
already yes
yep we're just having slight technical
issues
mr lee i don't know if you're happy for
us to read out the statement
on your behalf
perhaps if you can indicate in the in
the chat or
if you're happy for us to read the
statement now
uh
we can see mr lee the issue is the audio
we're not receiving any audio
i'm wondering given that you've provided
your comments
in writing if you're happy for one of
the council officers to read them out on
your behalf
chairman just while uh the gentleman
says that i are typing that in
now just check so i know we i have
really we on i think you're
on the flipstem are we on the flexton
road london 432 flexton mode
is this the beginning of the first
representation or have we already
started
to be involved in this item or not we've
already had um
a representation like in that case uh
just for record in that case i won't be
taking part in this item
thanks very much
mr lee the problem we have is we're not
receiving any audio from you
um
i'm not really sure that exactly how we
can
resolve this
mr lee does appear to be on mute i'm not
anymore the um
it's not just me who's not receiving any
audio
this issue
no the written statement is there as a
backup for a technological failure
that's why we ask people to submit them
it's at your discretion chairman how we
proceed
uh ms lowe's is is ready to read out the
statement should you
consider that to be the most appropriate
way forward i think it
most likely is the most appropriate way
forward given that
we've not been able to rectify the issue
with
um the audio so as long as if you if you
can't read out the statement please
thank you chair yes no problem and
firstly thank you for giving me the
opportunity to speak
we weren't actually looking for an
additional venue at the time
and i was approached by the cafe owners
of 434a flixton road back
in the winter of 2018. it was the wrong
time and out of our budget
but the place looked fantastic and had
so many similarities to our place on
church road
right in the heart of the community
chain pub close by it ticked a lot of
boxes
we left it we were also getting asked by
flixton locals when we were opening one
nearer
us i got approached again in spring 2019
and had a partner who was willing to
finance the refurbishment so we agreed a
deal
and we set our opening on the
understanding we could get an alcohol
license
we went through the process with no
objections i would have thought if
people had concerns then they would be
raised
there but no one did i was wondering how
we got here
the obvious answer is there was a number
of objections which led
to this process this was based on the
planning issue saying we were operating
as a bar
a4 and not a3 restaurant and cafe
when i look at our business i would say
we were we are both
a3 and a4 we have done food events at
flixton with local street food vendors
and local businesses like what's the
catch in amsterdam local
in amsterdam's local fishmonger and the
cheese court in amsterdam
so what is a3 and a4 i've taken
i've taken this i've taken the
description from the trafford
um council portal an a3 restaurant
and cafe for the sale of food and drink
for the consumption on the premises
restaurants snack bars and cafes an a4
is a drinking establishment public
houses wine bars and other drinking
establishments but not nightclubs
including drinking establishments with
expanded food provision rightly or
wrongly we thought we were okay at a3 as
we are a bar that frequently does
food we are asked to apply for planning
permission for the change of use from a3
to a4
having been open and operating since
november 2019
a total of 15 months the objectives came
back with
several dubious ones to say the least
out of the ten objectives two have
removed their objections
two are no longer relevant as they do
not live in the area
four are just bit lies based on the fact
that we never use the outside area
which ian elliot can confirm
leaving just miss eldri and mrs
alex brody all of which i
submitted to tom parkinson ahead of this
meeting as part of my defense
the work myself and tom parkinson over
the last year have done has been
extensive
and i want to thank tom for his guidance
and help
however being stopped by the head of
planning at the 11th hour has caused
both stress and anxiety to me at what
had already been a hugely difficult time
for the hospitality industry
i could perhaps understand if we had
never opened
but we have been trading for 15 months
prior to this and are established an
integral part
of the flixton community i would have
preferred to address
the issue considering the site's
location out of the town centre
and not close to any other late night
pubs or bars
at the beginning of the process back in
april 2020 i might not have spent such
huge
huge sums of money and time and just
shut
taking the grant money and leaving an
mpg shop on the high street
but i didn't we add value to the
community
i think i have answered concerns naming
the church in 500 yards away
john alka 300 yards away and trafford's
own flicked
flixton house 300 yards away along with
your added comments that they don't have
apartments above
i included brew chimp on church road
which has an apartment above it
and is 200 yards from the road book
while except that planning could not
check every part of the building where
undertaking
undertaken the fact remains that if the
acoustic ceiling had been installed in
2010 by the previous tenant
we would not be here today as there
would no be there would be no noise
issues
the extensive work by installing the
missing acoustic ceiling from 2010
with the noise assessments and on the
testimony of phil webb
directly above the bar and
other neighbors next door all the noisy
issues have been addressed
we have a strong link to the community
there are people from every walk of life
coming in
some on their way home from the train
having a quick paint
someone walking the dog family calling
in after being on the park
as we know from opening brew chimp on
church road
we no longer are the owners as the place
developed into what the community wants
this is what happened at flixton it is
uniquely different to church road
and somewhat more subdued but regardless
it belongs to flixton
are there any members looking to open
the bay
nobody's indicating i was wondering if i
could just
perhaps ask for some um advice i suppose
from
uh the planning department because i
understand that
at least my reading of the report is
that the environmental health
team that the council no longer object
on the basis of noise nuisance and i was
just wondering if we could talk through
um the distinction between what the
planning department
are considering and
the thinking of the environmental health
team given that the basis for refusal is
largely
um impacts on residential immunity of
neighbouring properties
as a consequence of noise good
appreciate
him happy putting you on the spot that
must come no no problem
uh chairman uh yeah happy to happy to
clarify that
um the the environmental health officers
are are a consultancy and and their uh
only a quantity as opposed to
determining authority because they're
only looking at a
um a fairly limited remit their
their remit is too is is obviously to
consider noise nuisance and we take we
take their
their comments um extremely seriously
particularly
when they say that that there will be
harm but ultimately
um they're assessing whether they think
a statutory nuisance
would arise or not under the
environmental protection
acts whereas the planning service look
very much more broadly
at immunity and and living conditions
so um we're looking at whether um
somebody living above or nearby this
property would have
would have a a reasonable standard of
living that they should
should be expected to enjoy um
if if this if this went ahead and that's
broader because it also looks
at effectively at the baseline so um
one of our concerns about about this
expressed in the report is is that
this is already this is an area without
um
any uh other other types of this use
in in the row if you if you recall the
photograph i showed you all the
the other premises in the row are are in
in in generally in daytime use i believe
there's a there's a
shop that's open uh late into the
evening
but generally don't don't attract
attract people in this
and that baseline and that that sort of
quietitude that they're
already enjoying it means that we think
there would be a distinct
change to their living conditions and
thus um
a um a harmful impact on their immunity
it may not meet the test for a statutory
nuisance
but nonetheless it would um it would
detrimentally impact on
on the enjoyment of their properties
thank you that's colby and councillor
thomas
indicated thank you chair
um i visited the site uh yesterday and
unfortunately i couldn't get access to
uh blue chimp although i would have
liked to have had a conversation if
if there are the issues
generally are the the l7 uh breaches or
potential breaches
and with the installation of the bi-fold
doors which i would assume
are there to be opened it'll negate any
of
the sound proofing that's been
undertaken um
with the noise going out and traveling
upwards um
there are still since i'm told since the
uh installation of the ceiling there's
still noise transgression to the
neighbors
uh on both sides although one of them
said he was nowhere near
the issues it was prior to that
uh being installed but other neighbors
have said
and said to their landlord that that is
still the case
um there is three shop fronts next to it
any movement out onto the pavement will
impinge on the
access to these short stores both sides
one of them
hosting will servicing and things like
that
so the number of
issues with people we're going past uh
such a long street um facility
the highway is also a main route for
children walking to and from primary
school just around the corner from
the the shop front so
on an evening on a sunny afternoon shall
we say when
people out having a drink they could sit
there
and basically have children walking past
them which i don't think is appropriate
for where it is also outside
people will be smoking smoke rises the
windows
of neighboring properties would need to
be closed to stop that
and again outside people talk so
again noise rising from the front of the
the shop
or the bar into family homes
kids in two of the properties i believe
um
i don't think he's um kids or school age
i don't think it's an appropriate place
to to put this
um whilst i agree that
uh as a small village amenity it's very
good
but i cannot see that uh
allowing the changes to include the late
night opening
uh till 10 o'clock being workable
in where it's situated so i i will be uh
agreeing with the officer recommendation
thank you
thank you and councillor proctor yeah
thank you chair
um yeah i agree with uh quite a
quite a bit of what council thomas has
said i know as a a committee we
we tend to take a dim view these type of
applications that
you know people have gone ahead and done
something and then
if they've changed and come back to the
committee but i think we need to
put that aside and look at it
objectively
um as an application in itself
um i can see kind of the business three
reasons behind this and obviously being
close to
lexington station it's a a potential
uh large flow of people went through
that which would you know create
quite a bit of business um
but i do think the the impact
on the neighborhood communities is going
to be pretty pretty severe
i do appreciate that the the applicant
has
made some effort to
make things better through the noise
management plan and i think it would
would help a little but you've still got
the issue that it's
smack bang right next to a large amount
of
residential properties that are going to
impact on this
and also people walking past
is going to impact on them quite
considerably
the issues i smoke that council thomas
has raised
is is also um a factor in this
i do know that the applicant um
did say this is very similar to the the
other property that they have
um on church road but i don't think you
can make
those sort of comparisons every
application is different different
neighbors different
impacts on the community and so i don't
think you can
you can make that to make that
comparison
um and we have had quite a few
complaints from from residents north
african it says that some of those
have been withdrawn or people have moved
but we've no particular evidence for
that
so my view is it is going to impact
quite considerably on on the local
community
and on balance i think we should agree
go
agree with other recommendations and
refuse this application
unless um you know can be convinced
otherwise by what
other people have to say thank you
thank you uh counselor and i can't see
that
mr leap you have made some comments in
the chat facility
i'll just clarify the the process we've
taken this evening
unfortunately the device that you're
using doesn't appear to be picking up
and transmitting any of the audio and as
a consequence we've defaulted to reading
out your written statement
and that's the sole representation that
you're able to make
to a committee this evening um now
councillor hartley you've also indicated
you'd like to
thank you chair i i think i'm probably
coming to a similar conclusion to
councillor procter although i i don't
think i've definitely made my mind up on
this one so
i do think it's quite quite
um borderline bottle i might be aware
but i think
it's quite a narrow issue in a way
because
[Music]
the issue is is is the noise the
potential for the noise and the impact
on
residential amenity and
i do think we need to bear in mind the
the current
use um that that's already been approved
for
for a cafe and you know as i understand
it the the principle of having
outdoor seating having people outside
was approved as part of that
subject to conditions around the hours
when that might be so that
that principle of having people outside
has already been approved and and
no doubt that you know there could there
could have been a potential for noise
when it when it was used in that way and
if it was using that way again so
people being outside the potential for
noise would be an issue under the
current lawful use in
in my view but i think the issue here is
and and i suppose just just picking up
on what
councillor thomas said uh i
i suppose you know i don't know what the
licensing situation was
with the cafe and that's probably not
relevant for us
but it will be possible for um
for that lawful use of cafe to continue
for people to be sat
outside if the cafe had the right
license they could be set outside
drinking alcohol when
when children walk past so that's the
situation we we could have under the
current
under the current um lawful use as a as
a cafe
what's different i think about this is
is the is the
extension in the hours so it's the
extension in the opening hours that's
proposed
combined with that potential for noise
so
whereas you know the noise at the moment
at um
you know four o'clock five o'clock is is
something that that you know would be
would be lawfully fine you know subject
to not being a strategy nuisance
um it's it's that potential for noise
later on with the
extended opening hours that are um that
are proposed
the design changes to the to the um to
the premises
i think are fine because the principle
of outdoor seating has already been
approved so i did i mean i did wonder
when i looked at this could we
is there a way that this could be
dealt with through an approval and and
through
conditions and you know i've looked at
the plans and the work that's already
been done
so i wondered whether you know having a
double door at the entrance
uh would would help with the noise
mitigation um
take on board what counselor thomas said
about about you know smokers
so that so the issue here is you know
you could have a condition which
said you know no outdoor seating after
nine o'clock or whatever your condition
was but i think the you know the
understandable concerns for residents is
that people will still go outside
uh at closing time on the way home
people will go outside of a smoke they
might go outside over
you know to make a phone call and that
does cause disturbance
so you know then i wondered well could
could could the smokers use the yard at
the rear all that sort of stuff but
that's that's probably not for us to
speculate
about so it does i mean what's fairly
compelling i think is that
the sort of premises have been used in
in
in the way that's been proposed already
i think and it
has been opened later into the evening
and that noise has had an impact
on on residents so uh and i'm also
you know i think persuaded by the advice
from officers that if we were to try and
control this use through conditions that
that would be
that would be very hard to enforce so at
the moment i'm i'm minded to agree with
the
officer recommendation but i do think
it's quite a a narrow
issue of objection to this so i'd you
know welcome listening to what other
members have to say about it
thank you thank you and counselor joao
thanks chair um i think um councillor
hartley has really
hit upon the dilemma here in in the the
new opening hours will be fairly lengthy
i mean they are sunday to thursday up
until 10 o'clock in the evening
and then from friday to saturday that
they're up to 11 o'clock in the evening
and if you put that alongside the the
nature of the disturbance it will cause
to those people living above
the premises um i think that is
that is quite a disturbance to them and
i think we would be wrong as a committee
to
let this application go forward um and
maybe an application does need to come
back where there's more compromise in
terms of the um
the outdoor seating and the hours
allowed around that so
i'm gonna have to agree with off the
recommendation here and
propose that we refuse this application
thank you councillor councilman morgan
thank you chair um it's a really hard
one in some ways
um and there's a side of me which is
torn and would have
liked to approve this um i can really
see
why they wanted to do this um
are doing it um
[Music]
and i think council hartley kind of
made the very valid point that the the
the point about outdoor seating has
already been established in the previous
um planning commission um but it is the
timing
um and that's the real key and i
i mean i did some research in terms of
their
their marketing and their online
marketing in terms of
what they're um trying to sell in terms
of as a
as an establishment and obviously given
covert
lockdown means it's not open at the
moment and we're not talking about
uh they're not advertising themselves as
a
quiet wine bar that has a couple of
people in it
each night they they they are talking
about being a heartfelt community
but that has a very bigger much bigger
impact than
um um on residents and
i i find it hard to judge um and to
understand i can only take
office of recommendations for the the
experts in terms of the impact on
neighboring properties this in in a
different
situation this could have worked um but
i i i have to
um take the advice of officers so um i
mean i will listen to other
contributions um if any others are made
but i i am veering on
um agreeing with officer recommendations
on this thank you chair
thank you and councillor thomas you
indicated you'd like to clarify
something
uh thank you chad yeah it's just to
comment on on the front side of the
papers that we've got the report we've
got
that the previous cafe premises have did
rightly have
outside uh tables uh under the
last planning application or the
planning application that was passed
but a key part of that is that the hours
were
from 8 am in the morning till 6 pm in
the evening monday to saturday
uh eight until 15 100 hours on
sundays and bank holidays this goes a
lot further than that
and as i mentioned before with families
past six o'clock then you're getting
into children going to bed and the
impact it may have on them
um it also part as part of the
planning permission it was i think it's
two tables and the tables and chairs had
to be removed from the public footway
um after they closed us or stopped
serving outside at six o'clock
i'd just like to clarify that as point
as a point of uh
what the previous planning permission
was for external seating
thank you thank you and council
according there
yeah thanks uh i'm i'm troubled by this
one um
it's one where i almost feel that
the the community needs to have a save
beyond
the normal uh planning process
this this will check change that
the nature of that part of flixton
village
um if it's allowed so and i don't feel
that we
i it's got support for that as yet
um i i did i do remember the cafe that
was there before
i think i i'm sad to say it was the
worst cup of coffee i've ever had in my
life it was while we were campaigning in
flixton one year
but there was no way that people outside
that cafe
weren't making any noise it was a very
quiet cafe
so this is going to change the nature of
that row of shops quite considerably
and so i'm not you i don't feel i can
use the precedent
of the sitting outside it will change it
i don't think flexton's had a voice on
that there is part of me
that says this would be good for that
area but
flixton hasn't spoken on it it seems to
me
and i feel lacking in that i don't i
don't feel
empowered enough to change the nature
of that flixton village without more
support and what have you
from the community and so i i i i'm
supporting the objection of the
a supporting refusal on the grounds by
officers
but i do have reservations
thanks jim thank you councillor
councillor winston
[Music]
yeah thanks sure i'm i'm building what
uh council accordingly said i
broadly in favor of this i think i think
it it's
to have this sort of business there as a
as a community bar
for wanted better expression i think is
an excellent idea
and that area of flixton
is uh if you and when we said you can't
compare it to church road but if you can
compare the two businesses oh but
there's been maintain your car compared
to chess road i think you can
church road as a brood chimp they're
surrounded by a lot more houses and
flats than
this area of flextinnis so in terms of
the
the impact the impact here will be lower
however
it is the it is the length of the
opening hours i think which is which is
the real issue here
and it's supposed to pick up something
which i said which mike
said is fixed the need to say so in this
because i think this could add to the
area
i think what i really wanted to say was
if um if the african's still on the call
if as appears to be the way this is
going tonight that we
refuse permission for this i'd encourage
him to work with the council officers to
change the plans to make it more
acceptable
because i think this could be a really a
really good business um
but in the current format i totally
understand what the
why the length of opening is what could
really damage
it could really count against it in
terms of in terms of local residents but
i say again to the applicants
come back again with their alternative
plans if we do turn this down tonight
thank you chair
[Music]
thank you councillor and i i think make
a really valid point that
sentiments that i'd like to echo because
i i'd really
uh be quite comfortable um seeing
usage of this type in
in areas that are surrounded by
residential
uh units you know i live in stratford
and we have
bars that are not that dissimilar and
instructed town center
dotted around and i think you know if
they're done correctly
there's no reason that it can't work and
the neighboring residents can't
um enjoy um use of their own properties
without disturbance so i do think i'd
take on board though
some of the remarks that councillor
thomas made about by folding doors
and that perhaps and i think councillor
hartley also sort of
indicated uh touched on this during his
comments
that when he talks about whether or not
we could mitigate through conditions
that actually if there were some
amendments to this application we might
be in a position where committee would
be looking to approve it
um now just a clarify for committee
it's been moved by councillor jerome the
uh we vote in favor with us officer
recommendation to refuse
i don't think it's been seconded and
there hasn't been a
counter motion um i can't see anyone
else
indicating that they'd like to speak
up just like each other okay is there
any member
who hasn't contributed looking to
contribute
no okay i think we've had quite a robust
discussion there
um so it has been proposed and seconded
that this application be refused in line
with officer recommendation
um i'll move to a vote and i'm just
going to circulate through members as
you play on my screen
and councillor stannis support the
application to refuse
thank you council accordingly for the
application to reviews
support officer recommendation to refuse
thank you
thank you um councillor morgan
support officer recommendation to refuse
jeff thank you
councillor joe i support officer
recommendation to refuse chair
thank you councillor proctor support
officer recommendation to refuse
thank you council hartley
thank you sport the officer
recommendation to refuse thank you
thank you councilman kelly refused
please chairman
thank you councillor winston mate
uh thank you chair with a great deal of
regret uh support officer recommendation
and reviews
thank you councillor thomas i support
the upper
the officer's recommendation chair thank
you thank you councillor dr barkley
support officer recommendation to refuse
thank you
and i shall also vote in line with
officer recommendation
the application is refused um
now turn to unit one or tringum
retail park which is on page 13 of the
report
and before we hear from our
representation people speaking favor and
against
the item will be introduced by ms brown
thank you chair uh thank you members
hopefully you can hear me
clearly um whilst i'm
providing the introduction my colleague
ms laws is going to
share her screen with the presentation
on it with the slideshow um
this full planning application relates
to land and units at the ultra
retail park in broad heath the proposal
involves the extension and subdivision
of the existing home-based store
to provide a downsized unit and then the
provision of a new retail unit
to be used as a discount food store and
occupied by little
a similar application was refused by the
planning committee last july
on retail policy and highway safety
grounds in accordance with the
office of recommendation at that time
there is
an additional information report for
this application it provides an update
on matters of principle
and on some technical details and
provides some adjusted and new
conditions and clarifies the position
regarding the overall conclusions
um it also explains that two further
letters of objection have been received
including one on behalf of tesco stores
limited which members should have
received a copy of
there is nothing further to report
following the publication of the
additional information
the mppf is clear that local planning
authorities
should adopt a town centre first
approach when assessing applications for
maintance centre uses
the application site is in an
out-of-centre location
the focus of discussions surrounding
retail policy
have again been in relation to the
sequential test and specifically the
opportunity afforded by the sequentially
preferable altair site
the applicant has confirmed that it is
contractually committed to an amended
alter proposal including a new
little food store when having regard to
the evidence provided by the applicant
it has been concluded that altea is
available and suitable
to accommodate the food start element of
this proposal
the mppf is clear that where an
application fails to satisfy the
sequential test
it should be refused and the proposal is
also contrary to development
policies on that basis being policy w2
and post cs11
on highways matters the focus has again
been on a proposed new egress onto
george richards sway
and the potential for an unacceptable
impact on highway safety however
there have been important changes to its
design and location
relative to the last application
including its positioning further to the
west
away from the junction with the air 56
and the area where lane changing occurs
additional highways evidence has also
been submitted including video
recordings of
physical movements and further modelling
of signalized junctions
the position of the lha is that these
constitute significant
material changes relative to the last
application
whilst there could remain some residual
safety risks
it's been concluded by the lha that this
proposal would not give rise to an
impact on highway safety
which could be deemed unacceptable so
the previous highways objection and
refusal reason has been removed the
impact on a designated heritage asset
the railway inn has again been afforded
great weight
however it has been concluded that the
harm of a less than substantial nature
will be outweighed by the public
benefits
the proposed development will deliver a
series of important benefits
this includes investment in the retail
park the protection and creation of jobs
improved consumer consumer choice and
the retention of trade in the local area
it's also consistent with mppf
principles concerning brownfield van
maximisation
and focusing development in sustainable
locations
set against these benefits are the harm
harms
including the failure of the mppf
sequential test and conflict with
development plan policies
however the sequential test failure is
unusual in this situation since the
applicant is committed to both sites
on the issue of the harm arising from
the failure of the sequential test
the officer's view is that no such harm
is likely to arise
based on the consideration of all the
available evidence in front of the
council given the likelihood of both
schemes
being delivered in practice to delay the
application scheme until such time is
all terrorist delivered
would be to delay the benefits that
would arise from it
it is to be recalled that concerns
surrounding unacceptable highway
safety harm to which significant weight
was afforded previously
have been addressed paragraph 90 of the
mppf
advises that planning permission should
be refused if the sequential test is
failed
which is consistent with the approach of
development plan policies
however it is considered that there are
good reasons to depart from it
this is when having regard to the likely
outcome of the application of the
sequential test
specific to this case and also in
considering the collection of benefits
which are considered sufficient to
outweigh the scheme's harms
these are considered to amount to
material considerations
under the terms of section 38 6 of the
planning and compulsory purchase act
2004
which would displace the conflict with
individual development plan policies
and with a test of the mppf it is
recommended therefore
the planning permission is granted for
this revised application
thank you members thank you chair
thank you ms brown and we have two
people speaking to this application
speaking against i understand is judy
collins
thank you chair can you hear me uh with
cameras comments and just to cover
you've got three minutes to speak and
thank you for joining us if you do run
over time i'll just politely ask that
you
back up your remarks thank you i have
timed
all truman bowden civic society have
been asked by desperate residents in the
nearby streets to object to the revised
planning application
neither they nor the civic society have
been able to get a response from
planning officers
or environmental health in the short
time taken for this
application to come to the planning
committee if it is refused for a second
time
other society has been given permission
to use rule 6
at appeal the initial application was
refused on the
um sequential tests and on highways
given that altair
has yet to embark on phase one and
little
will be a later phase of three years or
so
and broadly already has asda and weight
rows
it seems obvious that a further
supermarket will impact on the town
center
trafford asked us to share a meeting
with amy
local businesses and residents over
concerns rehabbing good vehicles on the
streets in broad heat
amy was unable to suggest any remedy
weight rose has recently um obtained
increased
delivery hours because of home
deliveries and broadcasting zone for
further
industry in the local plan despite the
large number of houses already built
the proposed egress from the site poses
great danger on a busy pedestrian route
as vehicles leave the store they have to
cross a pavement where pedestrians are
visiting other stores in mcdonald's and
often have children in buggies
as the driver tries to join george
richards way
they have to look backwards over their
right shoulder to be aware of other
motorists who may be unwilling to give
way the journey to altering them
requires
crossing two um banks of traffic
um in less than 70 metres
the civic is always happy to speak in
advance of
planning applications coming to the
planning committee
um and it is unfortunate that it's not
happened in this case despite an
approach to little
we are great fans of liberal who we know
have been looking for a saturn year 56
for many years
and would um welcome an opportunity for
home
home base touring maine we are sure that
lidl usually tries to be good neighbors
and it's unfortunate in this case that
this has not happened
the elderly residents approached us
because they felt unable to address the
committee
especially online we've been able to
help and regards the
present problems with rats around the
site thanks to electricity northwest
we sent a team out to clear the site um
we do appreciate the hard work put in
read the traffic problems but we still
think that they do exist
and traffic past a desperate um
complaint from huxley street residents
yesterday
who say their lives will be ruined
perhaps little
at least would have the decency to
contact their new neighbors in the
events of this planning application
thank you
thank you ms collins um speaking in
favor of the application i believe is
nick
harvey can you hear me
me come mr harvey thank you for joining
us um similarly you've got three minutes
to speak and if you do
go over time i'll just pull out the ass
that you have with your match thank you
well good evening councilors and thank
you very much for allowing me this
opportunity to speak
my name is nick harvey and i'm the head
of property for little uk
i'm delighted that the application
before you has been recommended for
approval by your officers
by working proactively together we've
been able to overcome the concerns
expressed by the members of this
committee last year and with an improved
materially different application before
you today
including the revised access
arrangements the provision of more cycle
parking
and the introduction of electrical
vehicle charging points
the proposals would see a three million
pounds investment delivered into the
retail park
and for trafford starting immediately
post
the grant of an implementable planning
permission
and to deliver little's first food store
in altringham and providing the right
size of a modern retail unit for home
base to successfully trade out of
if the members approve the application
you will do so in the knowledge
that 50 jobs at home base have been
safeguarded
and around 40 new jobs will be created
by lidl later this year and the over 100
temporary construction jobs will be
supported
during the construction as we hopefully
come out of the worst of the covert 19
pandemic
these jobs and this investment could not
be better timed
and as you'll know the previous
application was refused by the committee
last year due to concerns about highway
safety and sequential tests
in both cases the committee concluded
that the applicant had not adequately
demonstrated that the provision
requested evidence that the proposal was
acceptable to the satisfaction of the
council
and that the relevant policy test had
been passed
that decision is currently being
challenged by an appeal and with an
enquiry scheduled for june this year
so as your officer has written in her
report the application before you today
is materially different to the one which
came for the committee last year
and it is supported by additional
information
these include changes that have been
made to the proposed egress onto george
richards way
which the local highways authority and
the transport for greater manchester are
now comfortable with
subject to the conditions which we are
happy to accept
in addition and well should officers
conclusions about the sequential test
remain
largely the same in terms of suitability
and availability
and based on the information that we've
also now provided
your officer is able to make a different
recommendation
on planning balance including in the
context
of more up-to-date case law so i can
also confirm that little remains
contractually committed to delivering
two new food stores in altering him
the one before you today in the autumn
retail park and the smaller
metropolitan format store at the all air
site
is clear from the evidence before the
council and verified by the external
advisors
that a new legal and the smaller
home-based retail unit will not
have a negative impact on the wider
retail in all training as a whole
or specifically the delivery of the
second little store
in the town um in the altair site within
the next three to four years
by granting planning approval today
you'll be allowing us to build
and open the new legal store and the
smaller home-based retail unit
within the next 12 months by client
brand
granting planning approval today you
will unlock investment
create new jobs and safeguard those
existing roles at home base
and by granting planning commission
today you allow the applicants to
withdraw the appeal challenge in last
year's decision
saving all parties significant time and
significant costs
and i very much hope that members are
able to follow the recommendation
from the officer and approve this
application
and thank you very much for your time
thank you mr harvey um councilman
minutes you've indicated right to open
the discussion
thank you chair um let's having a look
at this and whilst
i really really want i do think the home
base needs
um and i said this last time to be
honest the home base does need to change
to move times to actually make it a
viable business
and i support that part of this if that
makes any sense
um i'm still concerned about road safety
and
the level of traffic the egress
i think is still um not
safe um it's better than the last
seagrass but
it's still unsafe and the whole idea i
know it's one when you come out and you
turn left only
i still have concerns the stretch of
road yes it's moved slightly but the
stretch of road
is quite short where you're trying to
fit an egress in
and whilst it's slightly better than
before it's still
in my view unsafe to bring something
unsafe in
and then if somebody dies
we would all be very sad for that to
happen
so i think that when we bring these when
we do approve applications
we need to really be consider think
about how
that is going to be in the future and
any potential
accidents that can happen so i would
pers
given that it doesn't pass all of the
sequential
tests and things and it has those
problems along the way
and i understand it's just about sort of
you know being
tweaked and whatnot i still think it's
too too wrong i'm afraid
so i'll be proposing that we actually
refuse this
application thank you
thank you councillor minis um councillor
hartley
thank you chair i think this is is still
quite a challenging
application for us to for us to decide
on uh
the office's report and and the
introduction we had was was really
useful and i think particularly the
commentary on the sequential test and
the recent
uh case law about that was was also
really useful
so i mean my understanding is it it does
fail the
sequential test um but the the
sequential test is you know is there for
a reason it's to ensure the
the viability and vitality of town
centers and and
you know usually that would be sort of
all important
and you know i do still think altering
him is in it is in a precarious
position it's going through uh you know
obviously a real good time at the moment
but we've got the uncertainty around
uh covered but you know the the
assessment is that
um that there will be no impact on on
investments
in in ultimate term center so i'm
reassured by that
so i know little are contractually
committed to the alter site as well but
i think the report does say that that's
obviously not
guaranteed it's not guaranteed to happen
and you know contractual obligations can
be
you know can be got out of if if need be
and i suppose that's the reservation i
have so if
little were to pull out of the old test
site then
then that would present a problem i
think because then
um you know what would the what would
the developer
altea do would that investment in altair
then be then be under threat bearing in
mind it's been delayed by
many years already which i think we
talked about with the last the last
meeting where the previous application
was considered
um so would it would another operator
um you know another food operator would
they consider
investing in altair and and would they
be deterred by the fact that
lidl was operating out of center on the
retail park
so i'm still you know i know there's no
guarantees a bit about this but i still
think there's a potential for there to
be
some threat to investment in the town
centre in in the future but i think it's
it's a real balancing act and i think
you know little are contractually
committed
at the moment and you know i'm perhaps
sort of speculating as to what might
happen
i couldn't i couldn't see any comments
from um
nicole isn't it nicole the um the
developer for altea it'd be useful to
know if you know if little pulled out
would they
see any threat to their investment but i
don't think we have that have that
information
so the sequential test i think is it you
know it's really difficult but i think
the report
does address it um paragraph one two two
is really
really helpful in the you know the
unusual circumstances at the moment
is that you know little control that
alternative site
um and you know that
so that so therefore there isn't there
isn't that um that viable sort of
center alternative i think um
so i think there are i do have a number
of other reservations about it
uh kentucky talks about the egress i
still have a
reservation about that the report
acknowledges i think that there
is a potential residual road safety risk
depart
despite the the improvements that have
been made so this is covered
um at paragraph 46 in the report
um so you know the lha commented that
there's no requirement for this new
egress there's no traffic capacity issue
with the existing arrangements which
which operate
safely uh and the new egress would
uh could still create could still create
a highway safety problem to some degree
where none currently exists uh however
that
does not give rise to an impact on
highway safety which could be deemed
unacceptable and i suppose the key point
there is unacceptable in planning terms
because i think in late terms
you uh i think residents would say that
you know any deterioration on
on road safety was was unacceptable but
it's
it's unacceptable in planning terms that
we've got to deal with
so um so i think i think the egress has
been
you know the issue with the egress
probably has been satisfied
although it does feel uncomfortable to
be
uh in effect to proving that when there
might be a an increased road safety risk
um from that development they i mean the
proposal doesn't enhance
soft landscaping in the area it's a very
hard and harsh landscape at the moment i
think there's a missed opportunity there
um it doesn't do anything to enhance
facilities for pedestrians or cyclists
i know it's a retail park and the vast
majority of people going there will go
by car and use the free parking that's
there
but i do think you know developers
should be
taking the opportunity to enhance
facilities for pedestrians and cyclists
you know and and the mppf and um the
core strategy
do do require that and and this
development doesn't
uh doesn't deliver anything to help with
that i think
beyond beyond cycle parking possibly and
then the design principle the report
talks about several design principles
not not being
met the design the design i think isn't
great but it's consistently
not great with the rest of the retail
park so in a way that that sort of
design uh has already been established i
think so
this this still in my mind there's still
are not a lot
not to like about the application but uh
you know the benefits are significant
the income benefits which
mr harvey outlined sort of the creation
or the
or the retention of 90 jobs i think
it provides um a discount
food shopping choice in altering them
where the where the perhaps isn't so
much of one now
it's also developing a brownfield site
and making best use of that site that
that part
of the at the car park at the moment
near home base isn't isn't well used and
so
this proposal does at least make better
use of that
of that part of the site um so
i think it is quite a challenging one
but overall i'm i'm probably minded to
agree with the
the officer recommendation to approve
this application
thank you chair thank you and councillor
jerome
thanks chair um yeah i i do have
problems with this
application still and pretty much for
the same reasons that i did before
and like counselor hartley i'd i'd i'm
not convinced the
sequential test it is met um and i do
think this application will pull further
from the town centre
i mean the institute of place management
who study town centers
come up with their 25 factors they do
talk about how town
centers need that range and quality of
shops you know they need a tenant mix
and and they need an availability of
alternative formats
and i think councillor hartley's right
in saying that there's there's no
certainty around the old
altair will it ever be built um
will uh little get the chance to move in
there at all it can be questioned and
also they're proposing a very small
um little shop in altair but a much
bigger one
at this site and you can see there are a
number of
supermarkets as the objector mentioned
you know you've got the asda which is a
similar
type of supermarket to lidl you've got
the audi there already
and i do feel that these will be pulling
from the town centre
and where the town centre is more
predicated towards
active travel walking cycling catching
bus or tram this is very much predicated
around car use
this place so this is another shop that
will increase the car use
at this site and if you look at the the
data that they provide on
on the travel management it does say
that this
this shop will be pulling in over 100
cars per hour
um and we know with this type of
supermarket people will be stopping
there for
quite a time so those cars will build up
on this
site and i think will cause highway
issues
so i don't think the sequential test is
is matt
in my opinion and i think it could have
consequences for ultraman town center
so i'm i'm i'm really i'm worried on
this point
on the egress i'm still not satisfied um
to me i think the lha is right there
will be some danger
still there and also the lha questions
the need for this all together
um so i am really worried about it i
think it does present a new danger
that's not already there
um but also it breaks up the pavement
lots of people do walk
to this site and now they're going to be
interrupted by
cars coming coming out of the of the
site
many of them looking for a quick exit um
and trying to
beat traffic coming from the other exit
and it might cause disruption
within the car park people trying to use
one exit or the other
um to get out of the site quicker
so overall i'm still fairly worried
about this
application and i think i'm inclined to
not support it but i still want to hear
what others have to say
thanks jen thank you i'm councilman
thank you chairman um i'm gonna have to
disagree
uh with the sort of uh council minister
and councillor george
probably far closer to councillor
hartley's position on this one although
perhaps i'm a little bit more positive
about it than he
in terms of the two um the two
main reasons that it was previously i
think the highways one as council
hartley quite rightly points out
is i think sufficiently resolved
although he pointed out quite rightly
that yes there isn't
there is a potential highway issue there
it is not deemed unacceptable
and you could argue that any change to
the a56 a single extra
car down the road is a potential
additional risk
but is it an unacceptable potential
additional risk
i would i would agree with our officers
that it isn't
um the previous egress yes absolutely if
i
uh if we were discussing that one now i
would i would i would not be happy with
it
but with it as it is now i think it is
it's
it's been resolved there are numerous
businesses a lot about a56
have equestrian access across the
pavements it doesn't cause an issue
uh the idea that people are going to
come out of that quickly
well not unless you only if you've got a
death wish you're going to try and do
that you're going to edge to the
edge to the side of the a56 have a good
and then
you you you'll try and sort of spot your
opponent and get out but the idea you're
going to
come out and cross the pavement section
quickly uh you simply wouldn't it
because you
you're going to have to wait for a gap
at the a56 unless you're
extremely lucky in terms of the
sequential test is perhaps more of an
issue
um but i don't think it's as
big as some speakers have made yes i
accept that the altair site is a
sequentially preferable site but has
also
been very clear they intend to
use both sides if anything it means
altair's interest to you know
the other side is probably the best site
for them so uh you probably imagine if
they weren't going to go ahead with both
who would only go ahead with the alter
site
and yes i accept also as has been
pointed out by
a lot of council officers earlier as
well that there was a three-year
potential i'm sorry it wasn't the office
it was the um speaker who
talked about the three year three-year
gap but um
oh i don't think that gap is going to be
sufficiently also
pointless uh judging on this basis
because i think hotel will be making
long-term plans and not not just
in the immediate future so i can't think
of a reason why unless the entire whole
test site were to cease to go ahead at
all
and the also wouldn't want to be in the
old testament it's not to no interest
not to be so
um with those with a small reservation
uh i'm i'm happy uh in terms of
sequential arguments even though yes
technically it's not met
there are good reasons why we can go
ahead regardless
we also agree with countless times we
have to say about the design
but then again it's rare perhaps to see
a a building on one of these retail
parks is a
thing of beauty you know it's it's
as i'd love to see a mock georgian aldi
at this location it would be perhaps
slightly unusual
um and perhaps more than i can i can
hope for
as for the cycling issues yes there are
some cycles but then it's not the cycle
so the site you're going to go from the
sun if you're going to aldi do your full
weekly shop and then balance it all off
your handlebars as you start
as you wobble your way down the road on
your way home
uh that's probably more of a highways
risk than the addresses
so overall chairman
i think aldi has done all that he can
really to work
uh with us in terms of this application
i think they've made significant
improvements from the the
time previous consumed of the egress
that provided additional information
uh in terms of the sequential tests
which has allowed us to mitigate the
concerns we had regarding that
and if i'm taking counselor hartley as
proposing
uh that we uh uh accept
officer recommendation i'm more than
happy to uh
second that if council hartley says he
doesn't wish to propose it then i will
propose it myself thank you chairman
thank you um
thank you chair um i mean i i supported
this application last time so
you will um not be surprised that i'll
be supporting this
again tonight and i will be seconding um
councillor bunting's
um proposal we accept officer
recommendations um i know i i
i sound like i'm echoing um some of
council even things um
comments um but i mean just quickly
summarize why i think
we should be supporting this tonight um
i mean just looking at the issues
um i mean we've got the sequential tests
there's
i mean there's two there's two points
first there's a point about um
um uh altair
i mean to go back on the comments we
made last time about how long we were
waiting on alter i mean i really
don't think we can kind of delay any
sort of developments
whilst the the decades go by um on the
altar
um development and secondly the impact
from the town center i i just don't
agree with
with with councillor jerome the the the
the impact
um on the town center we're talking
about very different
custom um the the this is in the town
center
there might be an impact on tesco um
um um a massive superstore on the edges
of the town center but that is what
effectively business is about it's about
making your own market and
and competing against your your own
challenges um
there's nobody's actually mentioned it
but i will mention the heritage asset
um i'd that because tesco did um i i
mean
if there is any damage to the heritage
assets um um
then it has already been happened and i
actually would argue
that this actually improves the heritage
asset um
um it's certainly better to have um
something being built behind it
than one great ugly massive car park
which has
even at the best of times um
next to no cars on it um i mean it
really is an awful awful
um sight on the side of the a56 and
the fact that we're actually going to be
utilizing this public space rather than
having it empty and not even using it
for cars and i know
a lot of members here would like to have
would
much much prefer i think all of us would
reduce car usage
but the fact that we've got a great slab
of concrete which isn't even being used
for what it's actually supposed to be i
think is a real
real real disgrace and i think actually
this is an advantage of the scheme
um i mean the egress i mean there's an
egress on the other side of the
um on the the entrance to tk maxx
um i mean and highways officers have
said they don't deem it
um significant risk so i i i i
i really i'm supportive of this scheme
um we've got to really think as well
about the impacts of jobs
um and particularly at the moment um and
the impact this is gonna have on local
residents um
um both in terms of little as well as
home base
so i'm really really supportive of this
tonight um chair and
um i'm happy to second council splinting
thank you
thank you um council according to you
indicated you had a question i can see
that
i think there hasn't been an exchange in
the chat did you still want to
contribute
uh and well uh no i'm fine on that
question
rebecca
thank you um councillor winston uh thank
you chair
i had a real sense of deja vu when i
read this application
uh because i don't think it's materially
different to the one that we saw last
time
and the the two objectives last time
were based on highways and based on the
sequential test
so nice i from my non-planning expert
point of view say that
those those still remain as
the two issues but i refer to the
in terms of the expert planet you know
that the the highways authorities say
it's it's
it's not unacceptable unacceptable risk
because of the the slight change has
been made to the um
to the new uh road that's planned
however
we say quite clearly it still fails the
sequential test
except we then say but the but uh it is
little i thought the
council bound to said aldi but it is
little we're talking about isn't it
just looking at my papers though
um the little have a contractual
obligation to develop on the old tests
on the altar site but
little if memory serves a part of the
schwartz group they're massive they're
on the same scale of
as walmart their contractual obligation
could change tomorrow
not big not because they intend to
change but because the businesses the
business model will change they'll
renegotiate the contract so i don't
think we can add
any weight to a contractual requirement
at this stage
so i'm i'm minded to to vote against
officer recommendation because i think
it still fails the sequential test
as our planning officers say it does
thanks chair
thank you council got to barclay
thank you chairman yeah i really support
the application i think it's making
um good use of the retail site it's
bringing it's keeping it alive i mean
that section
of the retail site is pretty dead and
it's good to bring it into life and
it will attract people into other parts
of the retail
um site as well so it's encouraging
people to visit it
it's maintaining jobs i mean i don't
understand the concerns
about um the highways risks but anything
that this site was used to develop
um any any way that this site has
developed would have
concerns over the highways and i don't
think we should in perpetuity
refuse things just because of um the
perceived um
increased risk now so and i think it's
it's an exciting development it's it's
got lots of advantages
uh our officers are content with things
they they have made their judgments and
i think they've made them
um quite quite clear so i'm really happy
to support it and i hope that other
people can as well
thank you chair thank you councillor and
there's no one else
indicating that the wish to speak at
present so i'll just clarify
my own thinking on this application
members who were
at the committee meeting um that
that um the previous application on this
site came forward to will know that
i i propose that um we support the
application contrary to
officer recommendation and a key reason
for that was that i didn't really agree
with the application
the application of the sequential
testing and the way that that process
was utilized
uh my views haven't changed in that
regard i think you know
altering and we need to consider that
ultraman town centre already has a tesco
a sainsburys mars and spencers and an
iceland in it
i think i don't think that we can pin
everything
on altair given as councillor morgan
indicated
that old tab has been in the pipeline
for pretty much more than half of my
lifetime
i think you know the world goes on and a
business wants to bring forward an
application to develop elsewhere in the
board and we should be
that they should be entitled to do so um
in terms of the highways objections i
can understand what
members are saying but i think if we
were to refuse this application
on the grounds of highways um
despite the fact that paragus 45 through
48 quite clearly explain
why the highways authority no longer
feel that they can robustly object to
the application
i think that would be a pretty weak
refusal if i'm being honest
now in despite the fact that i was happy
with the original
application that came previously i am
capable of recognizing that this is an
improved
application um as we heard from
mr harvey they've now included electric
vehicle charging points
uh they've improved cycling parking
provision
i think in paragraph 84 the report we
see that the
um council's tree officer is happy to um
there's actually an improved
contribution in terms of tree
replacement
i think they've said that we might
actually get a net gain in terms of
trees
on the site so i i'm quite capable of
recognizing that i think there's some
real benefits
to committee having refused previously
and the applicant applicant having
considered the remarks of the committee
and then submitting a new application or
a revised application
which may have enhanced the offer um
i i i'm happy with the proposal um
to support the application and grant
permission this evening
and that that's how i intend to vote and
now it has been proposed and seconded
that the
um approved the application in line with
office of recommendation i think it's
been there's been a counter proposal to
refuse
but i don't think that council proposal
has been seconded
and i can't see anyone else indicating
in the chat that they want to speak but
i will just give members a minute or two
to indicate if they did have any
further remarks that they want to make
now well in that case i think we have
had quite a robust
um discussion on that um before i move
to the vote i would just say
i'm not sure if mr harvey's still
listening but ms collins did
um in her representation um
indicate that she thought it would be
very welcome indeed if lidl
if the applicant could um reach out to
residents on huxley street and i think i
just wanted to reiterate that remark
it seems to me that the applicant has
tried to work to
improve their application and i think if
they can take on board that feedback
from
uh mrs collins that would be really
welcome and so we'll
move to the vote now and i'll just cycle
through members as you appear on my
screen
and counselor senate
recommendation to grant thank you
councillor
and council accordingly support
officer's recommendation to grant very
much agreed with you
and uh councillor hunsing and mark
okay um council minute
i don't support the officer's
recommendation thank you
thank you i'm councillor morgan
sport officer recommendations to grant
chair thank you councillor duran
i'm gonna go against officer
recommendation to grant thanks joe
thank you uh councillor hartley
uh support the officer recommendation to
grant thank you
thank you councillor winstonley
uh thank you sir against officer
recommendations grant
thank you thank you councillor thomas
thank you chair last time i was foreign
for it again this time i support the
officer's recommendation
thank you uh councillor bunting thank
you chairman with apologies to
council stanley and others for mixing my
brands up
um i i confirm that i'm supporting
officer
recommendation to grant thank you
councillor kevin support please chairman
thank you councillor procter support
officer recommendation to grant thank
you
thank you councillor dr barclay i
support officer recommendation to grant
thank you
thank you and i shall also be voting to
support officer recommendations grant
and that application is approved um
the next item on the agenda is
proposed stopping upon a highway at
white and grove
in ashland from mercy um just before we
move to a vote on that
um we will receive a introduction from
ms hendren
yes hello good evening everyone yes just
a quick introduction this
um refers to the application that was
approved at the last meeting
for the sale magistrates court it's
the stopping up order for ashton lane
and bratton grove there's four
sections that are subject to the order
and there is a map supplied with the
agenda which hopefully you have all seen
and we are asking the committee if they
would raise no objections
and approve the order
thank you i think council hartley's
indicated you'd just like to ask a
question
thank you chair yeah sorry to uh delay
matters
um it's it's with within my award ashley
mersey so
um so i guess the the area that um
is significant is is area three on the
on the plan so this is stopping up the
uh the sort of loop of ashton lane that
goes around the gyrator that's there at
the moment
so i can understand while it's necessary
for the development to happen
uh and it may not be a matter for us but
i suppose in deciding whether to raise
any objection it would be useful to know
what
what plans are in place for the traffic
there
because at the moment sort of all the
eastbound roughly eastbound traffic on
ashton lane goes around that
loop of road and and they you know the
westbound
traffic goes along you know the straight
section of ashton lane
and you can see from the planet there's
sort of various traffic islands
at the moment because of the gyratory so
it doesn't look like
two-way traffic will be possible there
so i'm just
just wondering what if you can give us
any assistance as to what the plans are
going to be for
traffic to be diverted whilst that
stopping up is in place
well the stopping up will take away the
any highway rights
across it so it will be it will become
privately owned it will revert back to
whoever the landowner is
and it will be used to construct the
development so
once the order is made there'll be no
highway rights um over that section
and the the scheme itself will be
formed part of a section 70 section 278
and the section 38
the details which i haven't got yet um
i can certainly speak to jeff in the
morning to see if he's had anything
to my knowledge we've not had the
designs yet
yeah well it's perhaps something we can
pick up outside of the meeting because
i suppose the question is where where's
where's that eastbourne traffic going to
go
if it you know once this stopping up
orders in place
um so i think that's something that
we uh well certainly as a water council
i want some further information on and
residents would need to be
sort of clearly advised about what those
arrangements were
absolutely yeah yeah as i say when um
when i get into the morning i'll have a
word with jeff
this is one of the projects that he's
been leaving on and
as i say to my knowledge we haven't got
the highway designs yet but i will
speak to him just to see what
information he's got
thank you thank you mrs hendrick um
committee's been asked that we raised no
objection to this
uh stopping the border i'm happy to
propose to that effect is
anyone happy to second that
second chair thank you councillor thomas
[Music]
um
can't see anybody wishing uh indicating
that they'd like to speak
and as such uh just move to a vote
um that we raised no objection to the
proposed stopping of borders
move through members as you hear from my
screen and
counselor's done it
here thank you uh
council accordingly support the
recommendation chair
thank you councillor minis um i support
the recommendation thank you chair thank
you
councilman morgan support the
recommendation jeff
thank you uh council jerome let's
support the recommendation chair
thank you councillor hartley thank you
chair support the recommendation
thank you councillor winston
uh thank you chair support the
recommendation thank you
councillor thomas for the recommendation
chair thank you
thank you council voting for the
recommendations
thank you thank you councillor kerry
uh support please chairman thank you
councillor
proctor support
thank you councillor dr barkley i
support the recommendation
thank you and i shall also be fitting to
support the recommendation
and no objection is raised to that
stopping recorder
um next agenda item is urgent business
i haven't been notified of any urgent
business
and i did however just want to take this
opportunity to reflect on the fact that
um this is actually councillor stanit's
last
um meeting of planning committees he is
due to stand down from the council uh in
may
uh council standing is a long
standing counsellor in clifford wood i
think from
1993 has provided continual service and
he is also
a long-standing member of this committee
i just wanted to put on record my thanks
for his service for his thoughtful
remarks when he has contributed
at committee and for his um friendship i
suppose
throughout my much shorter time on
council so
thank you councillors bennett i think i
speak for a lot of us when i say that
you will very much be missed um
so with that i think we're now in a
position to
bring this